Das geht mit lieben Grüßen raus Loki.
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier. Im MCU ist Hawkeye bislang der einzige Avenger, der noch keinen
eigenen Kinofilm hat. Dafür bekommt er jetzt
aber eine eigene Serie.
(Fröhliche Weihnachten!)
Und in der sehen wir nicht nur Clint Barton als Hawkeye,
sondern auch Kate Bishop, die dann seine Nachfolgerin wird und seine krassen
Fähigkeiten übernimmt.
Beste Zeit also, sich Hawkeye mal genauer anzuschauen.
Und das machen wir heute gemeinsam
mit einer echten Fachfrau, nämlich Profi-Bogenschützin
und Olympiamedaillengewinnerin Lisa Unruh. Und nicht nur das. Wir ziehen unseren Reality-Check
heute mal bis zum Ende durch. Also nicht nur
theoretisch, sondern auch praktisch,
denn wir werden basteln. Wir werden drei Spezialpfeile
nachbauen und gemeinsam mit Lisa abschießen.
Die wichtigste Frage an Euch aber: Habt Ihr die Serie schon gesehen? Und wenn ja,
wie hat sie euch bislang gefallen? Lasst mir mal einen Kommentar dazu da.
Aber bevor wir jetzt direkt los basteln, wollen
wir uns die Dinger hier noch ein bisschen
genauer anschauen. Die drei coolsten Pfeile
fasst uns jetzt noch mal jemand zusammen,
der sich mit Marvel bestens auskennt, nämlich
Luc vom Kanal Nerdfactory.
Hey Jack! Erstmal zu den harten Fakten. Hawkeye hat
einen Köcher, in den maximal 32 Pfeile passen.
Das spezielle an diesen Köchern ist,
dass die Pfeile da noch nicht fertig drin sind,
sondern in Pfeilschaft und Spitzen getrennt.
Das heißt, Hawkeye kann sich für jeden Schuss
spontan aussuchen, welche Pfeilspitze er gerade braucht.
Ziemlich nützlich ist der Abseil-Pfeil und
der ist keiner zum Angreifen, sondern eher ein Notfallplan. Hawkeye schießt im freien
Fall einen Haken mit Seil dran an eine Hauswand
und lässt sich so vom Gebäude abseilen und retten.
Das, was ihn aber am meisten ausmacht,
ist natürlich seine unfassbare Präzision. Er kann kleinste Ziele auf krasse Distanzen treffen
und das beweist ja zum Beispiel mit dem Hack-Pfeil.
An der Pfeilspitze ist ein Datenspeicher
mit Schadsoftware befestigt und die schießt er
direkt in den Port eines Computers.
Der dritte Pfeil, den Ihr unbedingt testen solltet, ist ein echter Klassiker. Der Explosions-Pfeil.
Den gab es schon in den Comics und in den Filmen sehen wir ihn permanent. Die Pfeilspitze
ist ein Sprengkörper, der beim Aufprall explodiert,
aber Hawkeye kann ihn auch ferngesteuert hochjagen.
Danke, Luc! Dann haben wir in unserer Bastelwerkstatt
also drei Aspekte, auf die wir unsere Pfeile überprüfen:
Gadgets, Präzision und Explosion.
Und darauf freue ich mich schon am meisten.
Es hat übelst viel Spaß gemacht, sich das alles zu überlegen und zusammenzustellen.
Und das coole ist ja, mit echten Pfeilen kann
man auch viel besser die tatsächliche Physik überprüfen.
Habe ich da Physik gehört?
Hey Anne! Schön, dass Du da bist! Rechnen wir heute etwas mit Formeln?
Ich denke schon!
- Mega gut!
(Ich liebe euch Leute).
Wir haben uns richtige High-End-Pfeile besorgt.
Die sind aus Aluminium und mit Carbon beschichtet.
Das heißt, sie sind superleicht, trotzdem
sehr stabil und deswegen auch Standard im Profibogensport.
Und diese Pfeile bekommen von uns jetzt ein richtiges Hawkeye-Upgrade
Und wir fangen mit dem Abseil-Pfeil an. Da habe ich versucht, etwas möglichst leichtes
und trotzdem stabiles zu finden. Das war gar
nicht so einfach. Aber ich bin dann im Netz
auf diesen Kletterhaken hier gestoßen. Den würde ich jetzt mit dem Pfeil verbinden und
das machen wir mit Gaffer.
Okay! Der ist jetzt nicht ganz so filigran
wie der von Hawkeye, aber dafür, dass wir keine Spieltechnik zur Verfügung haben,
finde ich macht Gaffer hier schon von einem guten Job.
Und als Gegner würde ich vor dem Ding auf jeden Fall abhauen. Fakt ist aber,
sowohl dieser Pfeil als auch der Abseil-Pfeil von
Hawkeye sind deutlich schwerer als ein normaler.
Das heißt, die würden auch anders fliegen.
Ja, würden sie auf jeden Fall. Und das können
wir auch ganz einfach sehen. Dafür gucken wir uns mal an, was für eine Energie so ein Pfeil hat.
Wenn Hawkeye den Pfeil in den Bogen spannt,
dann hat er ja erst einmal keine kinetische
Energie. Der Pfeil ist ja noch nicht losgeflogen.
Aber durch das spannen speichert er Energie in dem Bogen. Und diese gespeicherte Energie
ist ½ mal die durchschnittliche Kraft, mit der ich ziehe, mal die Strecke, die ich den
Pfeil zurück ziehe.
Und die Kraft, die ich dafür aufwenden muss,
ist natürlich abhängig davon, wie leicht
ich den Bogen dehnen kann. Wenn er loslässt,
dann wird diese gespeicherte Energie in kinetische
Energie umgewandelt. Kinetische Energie ist
½ mal die Masse mal die Geschwindigkeit zum
Quadrat. Und wenn wir dann nach der Geschwindigkeit
umstellen sehen wir, dass die Masse hier unterm Bruchstrich steht. Also der Pfeil langsamer fliegt,
je schwerer er ist.
Und wieviel langsamer können wir rauskriegen,
indem wir einfach die Masse bestimmen. Also
das Gewicht messen. Und da können wir
so einen Standardpfeil auf die Waage legen.
Da sehen wir, das sind 23g. Und wenn wir im
Vergleich mal den Haken-Pfeil drauflegen,
dann sehen, das ist natürlich deutlich mehr.
Das sind 461g.
- Also 20-mal mehr.
Und damit können wir jetzt die Geschwindigkeit von unserem Abseil-Pfeil ausrechnen. Wir stellen
die Gleichung von eben jetzt zweimal auf. Einmal für einen normalen Pfeil und einmal
für unseren Abseil-Pfeil.
Jetzt haben wir hier die Kraft und den Versatz
von Pfeil, die kennen wir beide noch nicht so genau. Aber das macht nichts. Denn was
wir wissen, ist, dass ein Wettbewerbspfeil
auf ca. 180km/h kommt. Das heißt, v1 kennen
wir schon mal. Genauso wie die beiden Massen,
denn die haben wir eben gemessen.
m2 ist 20-mal m1, das heißt, die Masse kürzt
sich hier komplett raus und wir sehen,
das v2 0,22-mal v1 ist.
Das heißt, unser Abseil-Pfeil wird theoretisch
um die 40km/h schnell fliegen.
- Wow, das ist wirklich nicht so schnell.
Und er fliegt natürlich auch nicht so weit. Denn die Reichweite ist abhängig von einer
Anfangsgeschwindigkeit. Der Pfeil wird ja im Flug von der Schwerkraft und dem Luftwiderstand gebremst.
Ja und wie weit er wirklich kommt und ob man
sich am Ende damit richtig abseilen kann,
das testen wir nachher gemeinsam mit Lisa.
Ich finde, dieser Pfeil ist aber auf jeden
Fall schon mal sehr spitze.
Nummer zwei ist der Hacking- Pfeil. Und wie
kann man im echten Leben am besten hacken?
Na klar, mit einem USB-Stick. Jetzt können
wir wieder dasselbe machen, nämlich einfach
den USB-Stick an den Pfeilschaft hier drankleben.
Das ist mir aber ein bisschen zu unpräzise.
Denn wir wollen das nachher tatsächlich auf einen Rechner schießen, sodass es im Port stecken bleibt.
Und dafür braucht man was, was ein bisschen
stabiler und wirklich exakt mittig ist. Deshalb
bin ich zu meinem Kumpel Hemmi gefahren.
Er ist Elektrotechniker, Bastler und hat einen 3D-Drucker.
Wir haben uns also zusammen hingesetzt, alles
präzise ausgemessen, dann am Computer ein
Modell designt, 3D-Drucker angeschmissen und
ausgedruckt. Und das ist dabei herausgekommen.
Das hat hier unten ein Loch und da kommt dann
der Pfeil rein. Hier oben ist Platz für den
USB-Stick. Ich finde, das ist wirklich sehr schön geworden.
Wir haben den ersten Adapter von Pfeil auf USB erfunden,
Ja und vielleicht damit sogar eine neue Trendsportart.
(Nichts davon ergibt Sinn!)
Und damit das Ganze nicht ganz nach 3D-Druck
aussieht, sondern ein bisschen Stil und Ästhetik
bekommt, haben wir noch schwarze Sprühfarbe.
Und dann gehen wir dem hier ein bisschen Avengers-Style mit.
So, jetzt haben wir hier das fertige Bauteil.
Ich finde, das sieht schon sehr fancy aus.
Und damit das wirklich gut auf diesem Pfeilschafft hält,
habe ich ein Allheilmittel gefunden.
Das ist Montagekleber. Da kommt jetzt ein
bisschen was in die Öffnung herein. Dann hier vorne noch am USB-Stick, denn das muss
wirklich superfest miteinander verbandelt
sein. Wir wollen auf einen Rechner schießen.
Also das ist wirklich Millimeterarbeit.
Ja, der Pfeil, beziehungsweise der USB-Stick,
muss ja genau in den Anschluss passen. Das
heißt, er darf überhaupt nicht rotieren,
oder muss halt ganze Umdrehungen machen damit das klappt.
Und wenn wir noch mal auf die Szene schauen,
dann sehen wir, dass das echt superschwierig
ist. Denn er steht ja auch einige Meter entfernt. Das heißt, von vornherein muss sein Auge
erst mal in der Lage sein, überhaupt scharf das Ziel zu erkennen. Anne wie ist das bei
uns mit dem Auflösungsvermögen?
Auflösungsvermögen, also scharf sehen bedeutet,
feine Strukturen optisch voneinander unterscheiden
zu können. Und wir können jetzt ausrechnen,
wie weit er von seinem Ziel maximal weg sein
darf, damit er noch scharf sehen kann.
Wenn du auf eine Wand guckst und das sind
zwei Punkte und du kannst diese Punkte als
einzelne Punkte wahrnehmen, also sie sind
nicht verschwommen, dann siehst du scharf.
Und das menschliche Auge hat ein Auflösungsvermögen
von ein bis vier Winkelminuten. Eine Winkelminute
ist ein Sechzigstel von einem Kreis, also quasi
wie bei einer Uhr. Daher das Wort Winkelminute.
Der Winkel, den wir jetzt hier meinen, ist der zwischen den beiden Strecken Pupille-Punkt 1
und Pupille-Punkt 2.
Wenn unsere Augen zwischen eins und vier Winkelminuten
auflösen können, dann nehmen wir jetzt einfach
mal die Mitte, würde ich sagen. Zwei Winkelminuten.
Und mit diesem Wert kann man dann ausrechnen,
wie weit Hawkeye von seinem Ziel entfernt
stehen dürfte.
Übrigens: Diese Anschlüsse, auf die er da zielt,
diese sechseckigen, die habe ich vorher noch nie gesehen. Mein Tipp ist, dass die
extra für den Film erfunden wurden. Wenn ihr die aber schon mal irgendwo entdeckt habt
oder eine Ahnung habt, was das sein könnte,
dann schreibt mir das doch mal in die Kommentare.
Im Film sieht das so aus, als wäre das Sechseck
etwa zwei Zentimeter breit und grob abgeschätzt
ist dann eins von diesen kleinen Löchern
vier Millimeter groß, also wirklich sehr
fitzelig. Und er muss ja alle sechs gleichzeitig treffen.
Wir haben hier den Durchmesser von einem Loch,
das heißt Delta y sind vier Millimeter und
wir kennen den Winkel. Das waren zwei Winkelminuten, also 0,033 Grad.
Über das rechtwinklige Dreieck, was sich
hier ergibt, können wir den Tangens bilden
und dann nach dem Abstand zum Ziel, Delta x, umstellen. Wir bekommen raus, das Hawkeye
mindestens 6,876m an dem Computer dran sein
muss, und keinen Millimeter mehr, damit er
den Anschluss überhaupt noch scharf sehen kann. Und das ist noch kein Garant dafür,
dass er den auch trifft.
So nah ist Hawkeye an seinem Ziel eigentlich
nie dran.
Okay, fast nie. Aber Hawkeye ist auch nicht
irgendwer, Hat er ein Adlerauge?
Und Adler haben ja bekanntlich ein deutlich
höheres Auflösungsvermögen als wir Menschen.
Das ist nämlich achtmal größer.
Und mit diesem Auflösungsvermögen könnte
Hawkeye 55m vom Computer weg stehen und den
4mm-Anschluss trotzdem noch sehen.
Also in der Szene sieht man jetzt nicht genau
wie weit er weg ist, aber das sind auf jeden
Fall keine 55m. Das heißt, diese Szene mit
den Skills würde so hinhauen.
Wir werden nachher mit unserem gebastelten
Pfeil auf jeden Fall die 7m vom menschlichen
Auflösungsvermögen nehmen und versuchen,
aus dieser Distanz den USB-Stick in den Rechner
zu schießen. Und ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Ich finde, dieser Pfeil ist auch richtig geil!
Luc von Nerdfactory hat es schon gesagt.
Ein richtiger Hawkeye-Klassiker ist der Explosions-Pfeil
und den schießt Clint Barton sogar ohne hinzuschauen.
Dabei hat Hawkeye zwei Mechanismen in seinen
Pfeilen. Er hat ein paar Pfeile, die explodieren,
wenn sie das Ziel treffen direkt und er hat
Pfeile, die explodieren ferngesteuert.
Das heißt, er löst die Explosion selber aus. Beim Nachbasteln haben wir hier zwei Hürden,
nämlich zum einen, dass wir ja generell erst mal diese Sprengladung brauchen. Also irgendein
Pulver, irgendeinen Stoff, der explodiert.
Und zum anderen, dass wir zwei sehr zuverlässige
Zündmechanismen brauchen, also einen auf
Kontakt und einen auf Funk. Und da habe ich
mich an unsere „James-Bond“-Folge erinnert.
Da waren wir bei den Stuntleuten vom Filmpark Babelsberg
unterwegs und da habe ich das hier
gesehen. Das sind Brückenzünder. Die haben
hier vorne so eine kleine Sprengkapsel und
hier unten zwei Drähte. Das heißt, wenn
man die verbindet, kann man das Ganze elektrisch
zünden.
Dafür brauchen wir jetzt nur noch eine Batterie.
Und dafür haben wir hier diese 1,5 Volt Knopfzelle.
Die reicht vollkommen aus und hat auch nicht
noch unnötiges Gewicht vorne am Pfeil.
Dann kann ich Euch mal zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
Man verbindet die Kontakte, und dann macht
es…
(Müssen wir uns Sorgen machen? Nein!)
Das ist dann also der Funke, der die richtige
Explosion auslöst und für den Zündmechanismus
habe ich mir zwei Sachen überlegt. Zum einen
das hier. Das ist ein Druckknopf-Schalter.
Da sieht man also, sobald der Pfeil aufkommt,
schließt sich hier hinten der Stromkreis
und der Zünder wird ausgelöst.
Für die Fernbedienung habe ich ein Wireless-Modul
bestellt. Und auch das kann man mit einer
Batterie und dem Brückenzünder verbinden.
Dann können wir ganz einfach per Fernbedienung
den Pfeil in die Luft jagen.
Das heißt, jetzt fehlt nur noch die Sprengladung.
Also das, was die eigentliche Explosion auslöst.
Zum Glück haben wir sehr gute Kontakte zur
Chemie-Fakultät der Universität Leipzig.
Die haben natürlich alles da, was so ein
Pyro-Herz begehrt. Und ich hatte da einen
richtig tollen Nachmittag mit der Chemikerin
meines Vertrauens, mit Marika. Wir haben gemeinsam
ganz viel ausprobiert und verschiedene Stoffkombinationen
getestet.
Am Ende haben wir uns für ein Rezept aus
drei Chemikalien entschieden, nämlich zum
einen Rotfeuer, das Strontiumnitrat drin.
Das ist das, was man auch in Feuerwerkskörpern
hat, was diese schöne rote, leuchtende Farbe
macht.
Und zum anderen ist hier noch Puderzucker
drin. Nicht lachen. Den brauchen wir nämlich,
denn die zweite Sache ist Kaliumchlorat. Kaliumchlorat
bringt uns den Sauerstoff für eine schön
ordentliche Verbrennung und das ist eine typische
Redoxreaktion. Das heißt, wir haben ein Reduktionsmittel
und ein Oxidationsmittel. Und beide miteinander
machen ordentlich bumm.
Und einfach, weil wir es können, machen wir
aus Prinzip noch eine Prise Schwarzpulver
mit rein.
Aber warte mal ganz kurz. Sollten wir jetzt
nicht noch Disclaimer machen, dass man das
auf gar keinen Fall zu Hause nachmachen sollte?
Ja, du hast Recht. Aber wir können das nicht
machen. Es gibt auf YouTube nur einen würdigen
Experimentierdisclaimer.
Warnung: Das folgende Video dienst nur zu
Demonstrationszwecken. Jack übernimmt keine
Haftung für Sach- oder Personenschäden bei
Nachahmung des Versuches.
Haben wir das geklärt. Dann brauchen wir
jetzt noch ein Gefäß, wo wir diese Mischung
reinpacken. Also eine Sprengkapsel. Da haben
wir lange überlegt und sind dann auf das
gekommen, auf so eine Einwegspritze. Und die
ist ziemlich cool, weil sie recht gut für
die Menge, die wir befüllen wollen, reicht.
Und weil diese Brückenzünder tatsächlich
super perfekt in das dünne Ende der Spritze
passen und dann quasi von innen hier die Sprengladungen
gezündet werden kann. Dann habe ich die Batterie
noch mit Heißleim drangeklebt und hier noch
ein paar Kontakte gemacht. Und dann kann man
das schon mit unserem Druckknopf-Pfeil verbinden.
Der ist hier vorne drauf, das Modul kommt
hier dran, wird damit verbunden und damit
ist dieser Aufprallpfeil schon fertig. Das
gleiche Modul habe ich dann noch mal für
diesen Funkempfänger genommen.
Da nehmen wir so einen ganz normalen Pfeil
mit einer normalen Pfeilspitze, denn die soll
ja in die Zielscheibe rein. Das wird hier
draufgeklebt und dann können wir diese Sprengladung
per Fernbedienung zünden. Und damit haben
wir prinzipiell alle unsere Hawkeye-Pfeile
fertig. Ich bin schon gespannt wie ein Flitzebogen,
wie das funktionieren wird.
Megacoole Pfeile auf jeden Fall. Hawkeye wäre
bestimmt neidisch. Viel Spaß beim Abschießen
später.
Auf jeden Fall. Danke Anne fürs erklären.
Und jetzt ist es Zeit für den Star dieser
Folge. Hier auf der Bogenschießanlage sind
schon alle ganz Hype, dass sie endlich da
ist. Unsere Profi-Schützin: Lisa Unruh.
Lisa ist seit über 20 Jahren Bogenschützin.
Bei den Olympischen Spielen in Tokio hat sie
dieses Jahr mit ihrem Team Bronze geholt.
Kurz vor unserem Dreh hat sie noch den Bundespräsidenten
getroffen, also in Persona
Lisa, wie schön, dass Du da bist. Ich freu
mich!
Ich mich auch, danke, dass ich kommen durfte!
Wollen wir erst mal so auf Hawkeyes Equipment
und seine generellen Skills schauen. Der Bogen,
den er hat, ist das ein Profi-Sportgerät?
Ich würde sagen so an schon. Im ersten Film
schießt er noch einen Compound. Der unterscheidet
sich zum jetzigen Bogen. Der hat oben und
unten so Umlenkrollen und die Technik an sich
ist schon ein bisschen anders. Der ist auch
ein bisschen schmaler und kleiner. In den
anderen Szenen hat er einen Olympischen Recurve-Bogen.
Also den, mit dem ich auch schieße. Und ich
denke, dass er damit einfach ein bisschen
agiler ist.
Er kann in zur Not auch überschnallen, also
am Körper tragen und hat die beiden Hände
frei, sodass er dann eventuell noch irgendwelche
Monster abwehren kann.
Aber an sich trifft man damit auf jeden Fall.
Und ist Deiner dann sehr ähnlich zu dem Recurve-Bogen
den er hat?
Seiner ist schon ein bisschen einfacher gehalten.
Der Aufbau ist gleich, aber da ist kein Schnickschnack
dran. Bei mir schon. Ich habe noch eine Zielvorrichtung
also ein richtiges Visier und noch Gewichte.
Dass es einfach präziser ist bei mir. Aber
der Aufbau ist gleich.
Und seine Technik? Also der nimmt, zieht zurück,
schießt. Und es geht ja auch super fix. Ist
seine Haltung und die Moves die er macht,
ist das okay?
Okay trifft es. Ich habe schon Besseres gesehen.
Also ich denke, hätte er einen besseren Trainer
gehabt, könnte er es auch besser umsetzen.
Also er könnte noch eine Schippe drauflegen.
Es ist noch Luft nach oben, okay. Und dann
macht er ja auch noch Stunts. Also er zielt
nicht nur, er macht das aus dem Sprung, er
macht Rollen danach… geht sowas? Also kann
man springen und schießen und sich schnell
bewegen und solche krassen Moves machen?
Also ich würde sagen, wenn man irgendwie
abspringt und irgendwo runterspringt und in
diesem Fallprozess quasi schießt, denke ich
ist es realistisch. Es gibt ja auch zum Beispiel
auch Bogenschützen auf Pferden. Das funktioniert
auch. Also ich würde sagen das ist auf jeden
Fall machbar. Aber um eine Ecke schießen
oder ohne hinzugucken ist etwas schwierig.
Er hat halt krasse Skills, deswegen kann er
das natürlich.
Wenn wir ihn jetzt in der Filmwelt einordnen.
Es gibt viele Bogenschützen in Filmen, auf
einer Skala von eins bis zehn, wo ist Hawkeye
einzuordnen?
So eine sechs würde ich sagen. Also nicht
ganz schlecht, auf keinen Fall. Ich sage mal,
das Grundprinzip der Technik ist schon vorhanden.
Es hapert nur an ein paar Dingen würde ich
sagen. Deswegen eine sechs.
Solide, okay, solide, sechs. Gut, dann gucken
wir mal, wenn Hawkeye eine solide sechs ist,
was denn dann meine gebastelten Pfeile für
eine Nummer bringen. Lisa, Du wirst die gleich
abschießen.
Ich bin total gespannt, was du vorbereitet
hast.
Dann, let’s do it.
Der erste Pfeil, den wir hier haben, ist der
Abseil-Pfeil. Den testen wir als erstes und
Lisa, wenn Du den jetzt so die Hand nimmst,
merkst Du schon, der ist schwer. Weißt Du,
was Du beim Schießen anders machen musst?
Momentan würde mir einfallen, einfach ein
bisschen höher zu zielen. Aber das werden
wir gern mal herausfinden. Okay, dann guck
mal. Wir wollen dort in die erste Astgabelung
rein. Denkst du, du schaffst das?
Ja, schauen wir mal.
Lisa, mach Dein Ding. Ich bin total gespannt
und mal sehen, was die Nachbarn dazu sagen.
(Das gibt eine Anzeige)
Der Pfeil biegt sich mega durch!
Okay, der ist nur ein paar Meter gekommen.
Einen zweiten Versuch bekommst Du.
Wir sollten weiter nach links. Kein Problem,
dafür haben wir ihn ja gebaut. Er ist superstabil.
Das ist schon mal perfekte Bastelarbeit. Bisschen
Laubarbeit machen wir auch gleich noch.
Okay. Versuch Nummer zwei! Lisa Unruh, let's
go.
Der war schon dran. Lisa wir müssen sagen,
Hawkeye hat ein bisschen mehr Übung gehabt.
Ein Schuss mehr und Du hättest das geschafft.
Und ich hätte mich daran hochziehen können.
Aber der Pfeil funktioniert, die Technik funktioniert,
Deine auch. Wir müssen noch mal in das Avengers-Trainingszentrum
gehen. Und dann klappt es beim nächsten Mal.
Nummer zwei ist unser Hacking-Pfeil mit dem
USB-Stick drin. Die Zielscheibe für Dich
ist heute mal eckig und nicht rund. Wir sind
jetzt hier sieben Meter entfernt, also das
Auflösungsvermögen vom menschlichen Auge,
für die Größe des USB-Slots.
Erkennst Du den von hier?
Ja, klar. Da sind sogar zwei übereinander.
Genau. Du hast die doppelte Chance. Was ist
hier die Schwierigkeit?
Der Pfeil hat durch den Anschub eine gewisse
Biegung und ob die Biegung da vorne auch gerade
ist, ist die Frage.
Wir probieren es. Dann würde ich Dir den
mal geben. Also entweder geht der Tower kaputt,
der Pfeil geht kaputt oder beides. Oder meine
Bastelehre.
Er steckt auf jeden Fall! Ich würde sagen,
der Rechner ist gehackt. Nicht ganz so, wie
wir es uns vorgestellt haben. Schadsoftware
brauchen wir hier nicht mehr, aber getroffen
ist er.
(Einige Leute nennen mich tatsächlich die
beste Bogenschützin der Welt).
Willkommen zum Grande Finale mit dem Hawkeye-Explosions-Pfeil
mit Druckknopf-Explosionsschalter. Das ist
ein kleiner Taster und wenn er dann vorne
gegen die Zielscheibe bumst, äh, dann bumms.
Ach was. Ich habe hier auch so einen Druckknopf.
Und kann das Ding auch explodieren?
Gott sei Dank nicht.
Sehr gut. Das Ding ist schon scharf. Wir müssen
jetzt sehr aufpassen, wenn Du das einspannst.
Nicht fallen lassen.
Nichts passiert! Keine Explosion. Was ist
los? Warum?
Das Ding ist kaputt, schade. Ja, er hat den
Kontakt zerstört. Du warst zu schnell.
Ich war zu schnell? Ich bin jetzt schuld?
Ach so. Ja, die Schuldfrage muss natürlich
geklärt werden.
Ich wollte sagen, ich habe falsch gebastelt.
Nein, ich wollte damit nur sagen, wir haben
es so schnell geschossen, dass es die Batterie
abgemacht hat, bevor der Druckkopf hier gedrückt
werden konnte. Und damit ist nichts hochgegangen,
okay. Das war bei Hawkeye einfacher. Eine
Chance haben wir noch.
Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht muss ich
ehrlich sagen. Und ich bin auch ein bisschen
wütend, dass nichts funktioniert hat. Und
deswegen ziehen wir jetzt das größte Ass,
was wir im Ärmel haben. Das ist dieser geile
Funkpfeil. Fernbedienung geht an, Fernbedienung
geht aus. Noch ist nichts verbunden. Sprengladung
ist sicher. Und weil ich so sackig bin, muss
es aber jetzt eine fette Explosion werden.
Wir machen jetzt einfach hier ein bisschen
Spiritus drauf. Ja, ein bisschen. An die Zielscheibe
muss natürlich auch noch was.
Es muss funktionieren jetzt. Noch nicht schießen.
Letzter Versuch: Avengers Style. Let's go!
Das geht mit lieben Grüßen raus Loki.
Vielleicht können wir das löschen? Die GoPro
noch irgendwie retten vielleicht?
Geiler Scheiß hier, super!
Lisa, vielen Dank, dass Du das mitgemacht
hast. Schaut mal in die Infobox, da gibt es
einen Link zu Lisas Instagram-Profil und auch
einen Link zu „Jäger und Sammler“, der
Bogenschießanlage hier in Berlin, bei der
wir zu Gast waren.
Die haben alles mit uns mitgemacht, großen
Dank an die. Es war ganz fantastisch. Danke
doch raus an Luc vom Kanal Nerdfactory und
natürlich an Anne fürs erklären. Ich freue
mich, wenn Ihr abonnieren drückt und unsere
Glocke, dann können wir uns bald wiedersehen.
Ich freue mich bis zum nächsten Unfug den
wir machen. Lisa vielen Dank!
Wenn es Euch bis hierhin gefallen hat, dann
schaut doch auch mal bei Luc vorbei. Der hat
sich nämlich die gesamte Serie noch ein bisschen
genauer angesehen. Und weil ich seit ein paar
Tagen nicht schlafen kann, weil dieser Druckmechanismus
eigentlich funktioniert hat, seht hier noch
mal die Szene aus unserer Bastelaction, wo
es tatsächlich geklappt hat.